My genetic test showed that my cancer is fed by glucose. You suggested a keto-like diet. Please
explain this diet more in terms of amounts of meat. Vegetables, grains, cooked, or raw still feel
confusion to what to eat. Well, it is confusing on what to eat because everybody's different. And
you know, if you want a full ketogenic diet, the problem with that is you're not going to know what to
eat because you typically have to stay away from dairy too because dairy, even if that isn't a
driver for your cancer, it can quickly become a driver for your cancer for people who are
doing a ketogenic diet because typically ketogenic diets are very high in dairy and then your
cancer can easily switch to becoming fed on dairy. So you're doing a ketogenic diet that's low in
dairy. Well, what are you going to eat? Just meat. It's difficult. You need some other things.
So that's why I always suggest a keto-like diet and you have to kind of watch where you're
getting enough food to stay, have energy, getting enough carbohydrates to have energy, I mean,
but still not spiky to your glucose. So anybody that's that is their cancer is mainly fed by glucose,
this right here is your friend because this, well, this is your answer to everything.
So if you could keep your glucose levels in the 80s, perfect world in the 70s,
you are really going to shut down the fuel source of your cancer. So that's even if
boy, my mind is I woke up yesterday morning, it was 75 and I ate two pieces of toast yesterday
and some oatmeal. Well, then more power to you. There's some people that can do that. So
it's that's not even close to being a ketogenic diet if you're eating grains like that,
but it's the goal ultimately is to get your glucose in a fasting state down, you know, 75 or
below, but realistically that I've said this over and over again, that, you know, a lot of people,
you know, that are not 22 years old, doing a ketogenic diet. So don't look at the Instagrammers that
are bragging about how they've lost all their weight and they look buff as a weightlifter and doing
a ketogenic diet as the answer. They're also in their 20s or 30s and that's all they do is work out
every day. That's not realistic for most people who've lived life and you could actually harm yourself
trying to match a person, you know, like that. Don't compare yourself one to another. We're
committed not to do that. So the goal is to get your glucose levels down. That's the ultimate goal
in a ketogenic diet as well. I don't advocate using a ketosis trying to get into ketosis unless
a person has a gliolestoma or something like that, which is a brain cancer. So getting into ketosis
isn't the important thing. Getting your blood glucose down is the important thing. Remember,
you could work so hard on a ketogenic diet to get yourself into ketosis and stay in ketosis.
If you're doing it for cancer reasons, your cancer could easily flip. We fed by something else
that you're eating a lot of. So don't work that hard on that. Just just just measuring your glucose and
try to get that as low as reasonably possible.